muy buenos días pues efectivamente
revalidaba maná justamente decidió ir a
kan apenas se supo de lo ocurrido esta
mañana muy temprano 6 y media de la
mañana ocurrió este ataque y él ya llegó
allí bueno hizo un recuento de los
hechos pero dio un poco más de elementos
acerca del agresor explicó que se trata
de un hombre de con pasaporte argelino
que había llegado a europa hace cerca de
unos diez once años y que estaba en
territorio francés desde 2016 de manera
legal había llegado a través pasando por
italia de ese país de hecho tiene un
permiso de residencia y hace algunas
semanas había pedido un permiso de
residencia aquí en francia por ahora la
prefectura pues le había entregado un
documento en donde se detalla que ésta
estaba estudiando su solicitud por ahora
se sabe esto de este hombre además que
tampoco tiene ningún tipo de antecedente
penal al menos aquí en francia ni
tampoco estaba en el radar de los
servicios de inteligencia del país sin
embargo por la manera por el modus
operandi de este agresor pues todo
parece indicar que se trata de un ataque
terroristas ahora es la policía judicial
de cannes la que está a cargo de esta
investigación pero en caso de que se
trate de efectivamente de un ataque
terrorista pues en ese caso muy
probablemente será la fiscalía
antiterrorista del país la que se haga
cargo de esta investigación